[Music]
why do you want to quit yelling well i
was raised in a really wonderful home
but both of my parents
would resort to
to yelling let me reframe something
there were some really fun moments and
your parents did love you you were
raised in an abusive household
[Music]
what up what up hey everybody
we're at a barn raisin
here on the dr john daloni show are we i
don't even know what that is
are we barn raisin we're not barn raisin
no kelly's like we're for sure not we're
having a rather tinted mild podcast hey
if you want to be on the show give me a
call
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
and we'll you leave a message we'll
holler back girl at you and it will be
cool unless you ain't no hollerback girl
then we will not if you want to um go
via the internets go to johndaloney.com
ask ask and fill out the form that's
f-o-r-m
and it will just go to kelly and jenna
and then we will get it rocking and
rolling
if you're not into barn raisins then
you've come to the right place
we're probably more square dance than
disco wouldn't you agree
we're not really good dancers we're just
taking a walkers you are i'm not i say
we as a show this isn't a good dance
show
this is more of a vacuum your house kind
of show
like a mow the yard kind of show all
right let's go to becky in tulsa what's
up becky
hey there
welcome to the barn raisin how are we
doing
thank you so much i'm doing okay how are
you i'm good i'm good thanks for calling
how can i help
thank you so much for taking my call um
i'm having an issue in my marriage that
i i feel like i've come to a breaking
point so i just need some advice
okay um
my husband and i are a blended family he
has two children and i have one
and we've been married for almost 10
years
we took a class on blending families
before we got married and
followed the advice putting our money
together
and um
it's it hasn't been an easy relationship
from the beginning um and so there's a
lot that's gone on between then and now
but one of the main issues that's
happening right now is related to money
so
we had our money together
when we were married my son was nine and
then his kids were teenagers and so um
i kept aside the child support that i
received
from my son's dad
and we paid child support for his kids
my husband was very unhappy that i kept
the child support separate
because he felt like he had no say in
how that money was spent
and he was right
he was right yeah he was right yeah that
should have gone into the pot just to
help pay the bills to take care of your
kids
well we
because we were paying on his kids and
my son i used that exclusively to pay
for like sports band different things
that i didn't put into our household
budget i just paid for that with the
child support right and so
anyway that's not that's not the
question though but keep going
so the
over the years so after
his kids aged out of child support
he was
insistent that we then set aside money
for their support
out of our budget
just continuing
and
[Music]
so that has continued over the last
several years until now they're in there
one's 22 and one is 25 they live at home
with their mom
one isn't working they don't have a good
relationship with their dad
and so i went to him
last summer and just said you know i
think it's
time that we
stop setting aside money for them
because they're adults and we can help
them on a case-by-case basis if you know
they're in a situation that they need
help
but um
i think it's time that we
take that out of our budget and we'll do
the same for my son when he's you know
of that same age
and
he was so angry that he then separated
our money
and that has just caused a ton of issues
for me
i mean i make about half of what he
makes i'm working several jobs now
i have he shouldered with like our car
he has a free car through work so i'm
responsible for
all things related to our car now so
so
i was a super immature response
and
um
i would be willing to bet
that that money
separation issue and the holding it back
and this is this and this is mine and
that's yours that's just symptomatic of
some deeper rift in your marriage that's
probably been there for a long time
ultimately
how can i help you
so he
said in our conversations around this
that
he doesn't answer to me
in the
finances and he said that multiple times
we've we've been in therapy throughout
our marriage over
different times and there's a lot going
on like you said there's
we think maybe possibly um high
functioning autism he's just come to
that realization in the last few weeks
there's a lot of stuff there
um
but he has and even through therapy and
all that has never backed down from the
position that he does not answer to me
financially and i
i don't know i feel like that
broke our vows like i'm really
struggling with
seeing how to continue forward
if that is the view
well it's because
you answer to each other
yeah it's i mean
every thought and action should be in
service to your marriage
right so it's it's it even is deeper
than
who
because that's the question i get a lot
is like all right so we're split who
gets to make the final call
and usually if you if you have
whittled away a decision in your
marriage and it is final call there's
something else going on
yeah
right there's there's decisions that are
made that are the right decision for my
family that i don't like or that i would
have chose like if i was on my own i
would have done differently but it's the
right thing for our family a friend of
mine's taking a new job they're moving
to nashville um
i don't think they're excited about
leaving their friends i guess there's
hard stuff but it's in service to
something bigger which is our marriage
right so it's
he's not looking at it the right way
and
what about your relationship have you
set up
that it's pitted itself that way that he
feels like it's you versus him
my guess would be and this is just one
of probably several
when we're all on the same page except i
got this little pot that i'm just gonna
not budget i'm just gonna spin it
however i want to
and that is
maybe that was crack number one in this
unified foundation we went to a class
this is how we're gonna do this we're
all gonna come together bam i'm gonna
keep this whole thing on the side
and yeah you know what i'm saying and so
it there's no good to go back cause over
that's happened and it's over and done
with um
but here and here we are
what else is going on in this marriage
because there's something else
i mean there's a lot of things
from the beginning he um let's get let's
go to right now
intimacy scale of one to ten ten being
incredible
peel the wallpaper off intimacy one is
like i don't even know that guy
it's a one okay what about um
conversations about where we're going to
eat
like what for dinner and stuff like that
10 being like you pick no you pick oh he
did anywhere and one is like that's what
we're having
um it's it's pretty low it's pretty low
on that skill
um
we went last summer
how was it with my family
okay it won one because you went with
your family so it's yeah it's yeah
he
and
he and both of his children are
in theory on the autism spectrum so
any kind of
disruption and routine is difficult
so
it's i mean and this is new so i'm not
even sure like he hasn't been officially
diagnosed but it would explain like
a lot of the meltdowns he's had extreme
jealousy
but but i've worked really closely with
high-functioning autistic brilliant
folks
and when i know that
there's a different style of
communication a different level of
clarity in the communication
and changes
again everybody's different and there's
not we're talking about diagnostic here
but
um
that one does not automatically equal
the other
right so money is
money is a symptom here
what i'm saying is just because you go
on vacation doesn't mean everybody with
high functioning autism is going to
throw a fit
well that is what happens well i know
and what i'm saying is if there's not a
alteration of communication if there's
not a
weekly or monthly budget calendar
meeting that happens every time so we
can review hey here's where we were
here's what's coming down the road so
that when we get to that do what we did
we did do that we had a monthly budget
together in it like we did it together
except you had your side your side
pocket
yes yes i mean that that's a big deal
but he's had his as well i i'm
here's what you got to do
you've got to take ownership of you
all of this conversation you keep
rolling back to him he did this thing he
did this thing he just think great he
might have
the only person on planet earth you can
change or control is you
your thoughts and your actions so the
question you have to ask yourself is do
i want to be married
what am i willing to go all in on
and how am i willing to do this
and it's probably going to start with a
um hey i shouldn't have done what i did
or i wish i could go back and do that
over can we stop the combative you
versus me language you and you you have
to do a thing for me
or you don't run you i don't answer to
you can we stop that language and just
completely scratch this thing ctrl alt
delete and say okay let's build
something different
if you don't want to do that then that's
a whole different conversation right if
you do want to stay married
then you're going to have to rebuild
something different than what you have
and that starts with you taking
ownership of your participation and your
role in what you have right now
yes your husband may have autism in it
you may look back and go whoa that
really explains a lot
we had a lot of challenges in the past
with communication and with frustration
and with
all sorts of of
processing and i wanted him to read my
mind and read my thoughts and he didn't
do that and then i got mad there could
be a whole backlog of that great that's
cool the question you have to ask
yourself is what are we going to do now
what are we going to do now
the the statement of i don't answer to
you about money that's not the problem
that's not the problem
that's the uh jerry maguire moment
right what you gotta do is get beneath
that and say what's really going on here
and do we wanna save this marriage my
hope is you do
and if you do
starts with you i'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan
200. this is a paid advertisement in mls
id 1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to
michaela in
washington what's up michaela
hi dr john how are you doing i'm
fantastic how about you
i'm doing great i'm so glad to be
talking with you today i'm glad to be
talking with you what's up
well i'm going to ask your advice hey do
me a favor do me a favor can you talk
directly into your phone
oh yes yeah there we go perfect okay so
i'm calling to ask your advice on how to
stop yelling or raising my voice my kids
and for tools on how to help my kids
learn to listen to my voice when it's
calm
instead of them waiting until i've
raised it
oh that's a good question why do you
want to quit yelling
um well i was raised in a really
wonderful home but both of my parents um
would resort to
to yelling okay so
let me reframe something
okay
you were raised in an abusive household
and there were some really fun moments
and your parents did love you
yes
yes okay
yelling is abuse
and that's an unpopular sentiment and i
don't care
okay so okay i want to reframe your
childhood for you
okay what you experienced as a kid was
you felt the responsibility of
regulating your parents emotional
well-being
because if you did a thing
they set off
right
yeah and so the abuse comes the trauma
comes from a child having to carry their
parents emotional well-being and
children are not that strong they're not
designed for that sort of weight
right and so okay that's what you've
done your whole life and then like most
of us you parent the way you were
parented right so tell me more right
yeah
um well i i've listened to you for a
couple years now and i i've heard you
just tell parents that you just stop if
you want to stop yelling you just stop
and it's at first i was like oh how do
you even do that and then i heard you
one time compared to like if you were to
want to stop hitting somebody you would
just stop hitting you wouldn't say i'm
trying to stop
and that that was really um impactful to
me i don't even remember saying that but
that's pretty good i like that
well i i just it hit me because i was
like oh my goodness that i have no
excuse i just have to stop yeah
sorry i keep moving away um i've been
working on it and i feel like it's been
really good lately i just
i don't
i don't know how to
to get my kids my two oldest are pretty
good about listening the first time but
the youngest are you know it's harder
for them and i just don't want to have
to resort to raising my voice
okay so i'll i'm gonna comment on one
thing you just said and then we'll
circle back
you never have to resort to raising your
voice
true you never do
that's a choice
that is a nuclear option it's a choice i
will put one caveat
my kids running into the street and they
don't see a car coming i'm going to
scream my head off
if i walk up on a group of kids beating
up one of my children i'm gonna get real
real real loud
okay
um
little timmy doesn't take the the trash
out and i've told him four times
i'm not yelling
i'm not gonna say all right that's
enough adult now it's time for me to act
like a child i'm just not gonna do that
um so
okay so circling back
here is um and i got this from james
clear i think it's just it's been a
shape-shifter for me
so i want you to start with the identity
in mind not the tactics and the goals
and the strategies okay
okay the identity is
i am a person who never yells
period
that's just who i am i don't yell
same as like i don't like i'm just a guy
that doesn't get drunk i don't like i
just i don't like i don't i don't even
like feeling drink too i don't like it i
don't feel good i'm just that guy
i'm a guy that takes care of his body so
i like to exercise right whatever the
whatever the thing is
so you are
as of today
i'm a person who never yells
and so what i have to do now that i've
established that identity is backfill
that with actions that make that
possible
okay
i am a person who never lets my kids
have control over my emotions
they're not strong enough to do that i'm
not gonna give them that power because
they're kids
they don't have permission to hurt my
feelings or make me mad
i can choose and this is the language i
use in my house i am choosing to be
frustrated right now
because i want my kids to never think
that they have the strength or power to
make me frustrated i'm not gonna give
them that
that's good yeah okay i'm not gonna give
that to my neighbors i'm not gonna give
that to politicians
i'm gonna choose if you say something
that's objectively offensive
or ugly or i think it's going to get the
whole country killed or something
i will say
i'm choosing to be really pissed off
right now i'm choosing anger
but not because
i'm choosing this not you
you know what i mean yeah yeah so
decide you will never never never yell
and then create a lifestyle that backs
up the identity so here's how you do
that
you find the moments when you're about
to yell
and you're gonna think it's about the
issue and it's usually not
usually it's about a period of nobody's
paying attention to me my husband
included
yeah or i'm exhausted
or
i have a set of values and y'all it's
not about
um it's not that you're not
you're not
um
taking your food off the table that's
not the issue the issue is i've been
working here on dinner for four hours
and then i made it and then i cleaned it
and you don't even have the decency to
walk that thing nine feet to the sink
you know what i mean
there's a level of injustice that rises
up and what happens is the kid who's
nine goes good god it's a plate and a
sink lady
yeah
and then you feel crazy and that makes
you even more mad
yeah and so what we want to do is we
want to identify the moments when i'm
about to yell and it's if i want to stop
eating gummy candies i want to stop
smoking weed i want to stop grabbing an
extra drink an extra drink i'm going to
look for those moments that that pushed
me over and i'm going to be really
here's the magic
i'm going to be curious about it not
judgmental
okay
why is my body feeling like it has to
get this loud
over a knuckleheaded nine-year-old who
didn't take the trash out
why
and it might be
because that's just your your brain
defaults there because that's how you
were parented and that's how your
parents are parented and then here we
are right yeah get to the root of why
you're angry or why you're hurting
why you feel like you have to be a
volcano
yeah and all of that backs up identity
so here's how this i think i've talked
about on the show i'm not sure if i have
here's the threat i pulled from me
um
on sunday afternoons
um i was unpleasant to be around i
wasn't mean i was just a
i was radioactive i was just an
energetic presence that just sent the
messages to my family y'all need to seem
to be away i just felt it
and my wife brought that up because i
then my family would not want to be
around me and then i would overreact to
try to get like why don't y'all want to
be around me and then i started poking
and messing with the kids which made
them not want to be around me more and
then i'd get grumpy and then everybody
so i just cr i created a centrifuge that
made it people unable to be around me
and then i got hurt that they weren't
around me
and so my wife brought that up and i was
like oh man i don't want to be that guy
and so i started pulling the thread on
why am i grumpy on sundays i like my
work i like going to work
i don't mind i mean i'm tired because i
stay up too late on saturdays when i'm
watching the fights all the time or
going to concerts or whatever i don't
like getting up at seven o'clock to go
to church whatever but i like going to
church and i like seeing my people my
friends there so i had these different
like i like exercise so what was the
thread and when i pulled it back you
know where it started friday night
i'd get home from work after a week of
eating right and exercising and work
work work work
and then i would
murder
an entire large pizza myself
and i'd have two or three beers and i
would be all bloaty and gassed out
and all carved out of my mind and that's
not a beautiful picture i know
and
then i would sleep in an extra hour on
saturday instead of getting up and then
i wouldn't lift and then and so i
started a chain reaction on friday
that culminated in an exhausted grumpy
mutt on sunday
yeah and makes sense so
you know what really stinks i had to
quit eating pizza on friday nights
and i had to commit to getting up early
no matter what on saturdays and going to
exercise
and that has begun to shape-shift my
sunday afternoons
okay wow so i tell you that i was a
journey of curiosity
well what about this and well what about
that and maybe it's because right but
all of it was a backfill of i am a guy
that my kids want to be around on
sundays
yeah i want to be a joy to be around
and yeah me too everything works better
right so
can we commit will you commit together
yes
i will never yell i will never give my
kids
the power to affect me emotionally like
that
yeah
yeah i want to do that i'm no no no no
no no i'm going to do that there we go
i'm going to
yes you can
well and that helps having that um like
you said to pull that thread because i
think that's probably where most of it
comes from is my own frustrations with
who knows what but not but being out of
touch with that
and something just sparks it you know
and
can i tell you what
i'm not listening a common one with
young children is a sense of
powerlessness
and a sense of if they're not doing what
i say
it is representative that i'm failing as
a parent and if you're a stay-at-home
parent that's my only job and i'm
failing at my job they are my walking
scorecard and i'm failing yeah
i want to free you from that that's not
the case nine-year-olds do nine-year-old
stuff
yeah okay
one thing you've heard me say this a
million times i'll and i'll keep saying
it it would really be helpful if you
created a set of family values one of
them is i don't yell you need to get in
front of your kids and say i've been
handling this wrong and i'm sorry i'm
gonna make some changes in my life
and when i do yell y'all call me out on
it
yeah oh yeah that's good sit down and
tell me listen we're gonna make a series
of family values i'm gonna hang it on
the wall this is who we are and listen
when they don't take the trash out you
call them in and say it breaks my heart
that you chose to fill in the blank um
consequence
i hate that you chose to not go fishing
this weekend i hate that because you
love fishing i love taking you fishing
and you chose not to by not doing that
yeah they own the choice i don't have to
yell they're owning the consequence but
mom
dude
you chose that that's a strange choice
fishing's way more fun than
i mean it's it's five hours of fun
versus eight seconds of taking the trash
out but that's what you chose it's
strange but you see what i'm saying i'm
holding that so loosely there's no
reason to yell none none none
yeah
yeah i know that's that's good
the choosing i
think i've been using on my
five-year-old i heard you mentioned that
before and i've been like you know
when she's having those hearted like
you're choosing this consequence right
now because you're not you have been
using those words but i don't use them
on myself and yeah there we go
so let me hold the mirror up
you are choosing to yell
yeah
don't make that choice
you're choosing to do things upstream or
experience things upstream or to not
have hard conversations with your
husband or your extended family or
whatever these challenges are coming up
river you're choosing to not and you're
taking it out on your kids at the bottom
of the creek
so hear me say this as sternly as i can
yelling is trauma
don't okay
yep i believe that you're committed to
not
i am
cool yes because you
absolutely
take back control of the emotional
regulation and make that an adult thing
not a kid thing cool
okay cool hey sounds good you're eight
here's what you're doing i don't want
you to miss this
you're changing your family tree
you're healing family trauma and
creating a new family legacy this is
hard you'll stumble at it you'll mess up
and you're gonna come away with scars
and it's exhausting and it's frustrating
and it's worth every minute
because you're gonna have grandkids that
you have not met yet they're gonna have
parents that handle their
idiotic eight-year-oldness differently
because of the work you did
yep you're changing family trees and i'm
proud of you and it's hard
and you can do it we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com slash delony to get 10
off that's betterhelp.com
delony
all right we are back let's go to carrie
in des moines in des moines what's up
hi how are you i'm rocking on how are
you
good what's up
okay so um i am calling for some
guidance i guess um in relation to my my
kids um about nine months ago i found
out that my husband was having an affair
with my best friend oh
no
i know it's horrible um she actually
also used to work at our church um so
this is like this whole thing why not
faith concept yeah right right you got
one more what else
i know yes let me tell you did you keep
your kids too on the weekends probably
who knocked cheese louise i'm so sorry
dude yes
no you're right there oh
why not
i'm so sorry
yeah me too um but
our divorce was very quick um the other
side's divorce um definitely is taking
longer um but my concern is the kids uh
throughout all of this i've tried very
very hard to you know keep them out of
the middle of it
and i will fully admit that i've made
mistakes but
i think
i'm learning that my ex-husband
is a narcissist which is very hard for
me to admit
but now that that control is off of me
um i feel like it's on to the kids
and i don't
i'm just really struggling with how to
how to best parent them by myself
knowing that
we split our time 50 50. and it's just
it's just brutal and and i don't know
what to do
yeah so number one
absolutely who cares about the other
divorce
i don't care about it i don't want to
know about it i'm not gonna do i'm not
gonna talk to anybody but anybody brings
it up i'm gonna stop and say i don't
care i don't wanna talk about it
okay you shouldn't know when that
thing's final how about that
okay that's how far away i want you from
that it doesn't matter
she is not your concern and not your
life
if she chooses to be in relationship
continuing relationship with your with
your ex-husband and y'all get they get
married or something like that then
there will be some very hard adult
conversations that have to happen
because she will be conversations
between adults no you and her and you
and your ex because she's gonna be in
proximity hanging out with your children
that's already happening okay so there
needs to be some very clear not yet
there needs to be some very clear
conversations with her i mean with you
and your ex
okay about your expectations about how
the relationship with your kids
be careful about lobbying diagnostics
meaning i don't care if your husband's a
diagnostic diagnosed narcissist i care
how he treats you
sure and one would impact the other but
right now that diagnostic doesn't matter
what matters is if my husband is lying
to my children if he's not showing up if
he's blaming them for things taking
their money if he's doing things like
that
um using power to coerce them into doing
things things that narcissists do
then i'm gonna deal with the behaviors
i'm not gonna point back to the
diagnostic does that make sense sure
yeah absolutely so for example he
has blocked certain people from my
daughter's phone
that he pays for
and they happen to be my friends just
because he doesn't think that they're
good people or something so hold on he's
their dad and when
she's on his property he's allowed to do
that
you can get him a different phone it's
still his daughter's phone
right okay all right now when she comes
back to your house she can have a
separate phone if you want to do that
ah it's gonna have to do that that's
what i'm saying it's a pain um or
you can um
you can have your friends over when your
kids are over and you can just they can
have human conversations right so all to
say is yeah he can do that if that's the
if that's the game he wants to play so
be it
okay okay
and hey here's the thing
nothing is good moving forward here oh
that's encouraging
i mean this is all sifting through the
ashes of a burn down home to try to find
pictures that you can still see
exactly right and then you got to build
something new
and so how do i do that well it's not
this is nine months away your whole
world blew up
yeah i know
and you haven't stopped and grieved this
thing
nope
yes
you have to
no i don't want to i know i know but
here's the thing okay
how many kids you got
two how old are they
11 and 8.
so
you are a powder keg of hurt right now
and you are strong as bloody hell right
yep yep
and you
have taken out a bunch of plywood even
though it's super expensive at the store
right now and you have bolted that pain
down
inside your chest and that's where it
goes
yep and it still puts off heat
yep and your kids are getting burned
yeah yes
and here's the problem they think it's
their fault
yes they do
and they don't deserve that
nope they don't you don't either
i know i don't but i care more about
them it doesn't matter the best way to
care about them is to care about you
and if you don't deal with that right
that that nuclear reactor in there it
will leak out all over your inside so
you can end up with all kind of weird
stuff
okay okay
so okay got to deal with it the greatest
gift you can give your kids is to let
them see you be sad and heartbroken and
devastated and still in control of
yourself
and to see you have friends come over
and take them out because mommy's heard
it all those things
yeah because right now they feel the gap
they feel the tension they feel dad's
rage they feel that's her in this and
they drop off and on
and they're wondering what did we do
sure
my eight-year-old um keeps saying
if if i do have sad moments or or hard
times
he will frequently say
it's over mom the big d that's what he
calls it the big d is over yeah um and
that's hard too because i'm like no it's
not honey we we're going to live with
this forever yeah um
and so just
i don't know i don't know how to help
them wrap up
i think it's teaching them
that
the
it's a great moment for gift like grief
goes on for a while
yeah pain hurts and loss hurts and this
is what it looks like
and so there is ways to be honest and
when they run into life life hits them
in the mouth which it will
and none of us want that for our kids
but it will and for them it already has
right
right but when it does again they will
have a picture
of oh
that's what grief looks like and this is
a healthy way to deal with this thing
and healthy looks like sometimes crying
so hard i can't breathe
and
sometimes it looks like mom goes and
sees a counselor
okay
because hey you had plans
you had pictures of what thanksgiving
was going to look like when your
son had brought home whoever
yep exactly and it's all different now
you got to grieve the picture
but they're they're hurting so much yes
yes
i feel like i have to focus on them like
i'm fine you're not you're not
you got double betrayed the person you
would have called to tell them that your
husband cheated on you was the other
woman
yep you are correct
that is scorched earth
i'm talking to somebody who i think is
still in shock
and you sprinted so fast through the
divorce
to get that thing done
yep
honey there's a reckoning coming for you
and it's best if you have it on your own
terms
what does that mean that means your
body's gonna shut you down soon
oh okay okay
it will start looking like anxiety it
will start looking like rage it will
start looking like anger it will look
like trust issues it will look like i
can't sleep
oh i i've already had all of that oh not
have you'll you'll it'll be present
i'm not saying this to scare you i'm
saying you're worth being well
sure
and that means i gotta sit in this for a
season
okay mm-hmm me just
do you think you can just move on just
go i i don't but i feel like i have
dealt with some of it um yeah sure i
totally still have trust issues and the
waves of this whole thing are insane i
go from anger to
to just sad to okay i'm good too okay
all right so you are you're working
through it you are you are i am i truly
believe that i am yes okay all right you
are okay so i i take that so i'm also
very stubborn and refused to let this
affect my kids so i will do whatever i
have to do and go through whatever hell
i have to go through um in order for my
kids to come out of this okay and so
that's that's yes i'm dealing with
myself i have an immense amount of
friends who are incredibly great
christian women um hold on
your husband dragged your kids through
hell
and i'm mad
you should be you should be raged out
mad
but i'm talking to you so i'm not
showing that yeah i know i know i got
that i got that
you're trying to protect him from
something that's already happened to him
yeah
but it's still happening that's what i'm
struggling with it's going to him in the
middle it's going to
because your husband knows what happened
and the moment this new person moves in
there's going to be a new stark reality
because he's got his new person and he
went with him
and he went and he went with him
oh yeah
he more than likely did not like who he
had become in relationship with you
yeah
i yeah
but dude do you really have to sleep
with my butt i mean you know what i mean
like he absolutely didn't nope didn't at
all
didn't at all
and so now my kids too are seeing oh
that's mom's best friend who who used to
be super involved in our church and work
at the church and now
this is what's happening have you have
you sat down with your kids and said
mommy's best friend really hurt mom and
so we are not friends anymore okay
absolutely okay
yep and so the best they can in their 11
year old little hearts and minds and
their eight-year-old hearts and minds
that we're gonna have that conversation
and i'm gonna i'm not gonna bring that
person up anymore
oh and i would say things like i prefer
to not talk about her right now thank
you
okay
okay you don't have to engage every one
of these conversations
okay
the conversation's about um i'm not safe
or i'm being hurt or those are
absolutely we're gonna have those
conversations
okay
and when your kids get to be middle
schoolers and they start to try to
weaponize all this because their pain is
just bizarre and strange like like a
like a bouncy ball inside their chest
and they're trying to figure it all out
then we'll be like well she lets us fill
in the blank
and you will have to
swallow your soul and go yeah she does
but here at my house we don't do that
sure and that would be hard
right
yeah but i'm not gonna haven't really
thought of the whole don't engage thing
so i like that yeah now listen you don't
want your kids feel like they're on an
island
oh no i know that's also a concern of
mine yes yeah they can come to you
anything i don't i'd choose to have a
conversation about her right now thank
you so much for for bringing that to me
or are you safe yeah sure right cool
yeah
now my eight-year-old has kind of
changed to um saying frequently that no
one likes him that everyone hates him
and so i give him as much reassurance as
possible but that's really draining as
well as well as the emotional drops that
they
that's what i call them when they when
they come back from dad's house like all
these emotions are just dumped right at
my house and we go through this
roller coaster of crazy um but
do you have any suggestions on that
um your son is
that's shame
shame that is this pain inside your son
saying what did i do
okay okay okay and
fewer words more touching
okay fewer words
just sitting down watching a show
together and snuggling up
okay and making sure he's got purpose
and role in your in your home
okay a lot of times there's guilt from
parents i don't want them to feel like
they got to come here and do chores or i
don't feel like they need a role they
need participation i went through that
okay i definitely went through that so
now i'm trying to re-implement that um
because i learned that that was not a
good way to handle it okay so bring him
along you want to give him a good gift
go to michael's or go to uh hobby lobby
i just talked about this on the last
call get a big
36 inch um canvas art canvas and get
some paints or whatever and it's gonna
look ridiculous unless you're one of
those pinterest moms and if you are
congratulations and
you all decide
we're we are creating new family values
here what is that going to look like and
order their favorite foods and you all
have a fun night doing it and you know
write it down on a piece of paper and
then you paint it all together and you
hang in your living room
and this becomes a touch point that they
got to participate in because they
matter
oh i like that okay
right now they feel completely powerless
and it's just a bunch of hurt and they
have these fantasies that y'all gonna
get back together and we'll figure this
whole thing out and we'll just get back
to quote-unquote normal
and then the big d happening like okay
that's already happened so it's over but
there's still the fantasy
and
that's gonna be another level of
devastation if you or your husband gets
remarried all that stuff will is part of
this process there's no way to shelter
them from that pain what you can do is
give them a foundation that they can
absorb that pain from oh i like that
okay okay
okay
you were playing a really really long
game here a long game
you're pay playing a
25 21
18 they look back and say my mom's
my mom loved us through
a mess
mom walked alongside us mom brought us
into this deal
and um i had a role at mom's house
and
like giving a kid
seeing a kid giving them value and
giving them purpose
that goes a long way kids are really
resilient when they have those three
things we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right we are back dude you're not
gonna believe this um i've been hoping
we could talk about this on the show and
we've he's never given me permission
um james childs is a massive enrique
iglesias fan like
borderline pathological um he's obsessed
with him if you get in his car guarantee
there's a cd in there if you go take his
headphones off while he's editing shows
guarantees listen to enrique enrique
enriquez all we've talked about enrique
enrique enrique that's where he got so
obsessed with fender guitars because all
enriquez guys were blaring out these
telecasters or whatever
and so i've been saying dude let's talk
about that on the show and he's like no
i'm kind of embarrassed about it um even
though i'm super fan number one um i
have ei tattooed on my chest like i'm
super fan
uh i just won't talk about it yet and
today's the day today's the day and so
um during the break he brought in the
lyrics he's like this is my favorite one
of henrique's songs
and so here we go
if i'm j i'm channeling my inner james
childs but the greatest song ever
is hero by enrique iglesias and it goes
like this
let me be your hero would you dance if i
asked you to dance would you run and
never look back would you cry if you saw
me crying would you save my soul tonight
would you tremble if
i touched your lips would you laugh oh
please tell me this now would you die
for the one you loved hold me in your
arms tonight i can be your hero baby can
you just hear james singing this song
i can't kiss your away the pain i will
stand by you forever you can take my
breath away james childs you take my
breath away so much gaslighting
coming up on the next episode what are
you seeing as the state of relationships
yeah they're a mess we don't know how to
stand up for ourselves and be loving at
the same time we don't know how to
listen to our partners and not get
defensive we don't know how to repair
when the wheels come off we don't know
how to negotiate our
non-relational patriarchal
individualistic culture
does not teach men and women the skills
we need
to pull this off i love that you call
them skills
[Music]